Dance right?
Bitches round two.
We make choices like that.
We were on a network.
We would never just say,
hey,
can we do another hour?
Yeah,
let's do another fucking out.
How should we end this shit?
This episode,
this episode APP,
we'll call it an episode that is brought to you by Ting Tang,
which is a mobile service.
When they're going to stop calling him,
they were trying to discuss the side that recently,
like why do people still call them cell phones and mobile.
They're all smart though.
But mobile means like we can move it with it,
right?
Yes,
but it's so smart.
It's not just mobile phones or mobile.
Now if you have an iPhone,
it's more than just right.
It's not just mobile.
You have an iPhone five that's not just a mobile phone.
That motherfucker is a computer in your pocket.
Take pictures,
make videos.
So what do you think we should call it?
Better name than a smartphone.
Some of the people in charge of names come up with a better name because fucking
job.
The point is ting has phones for sale folks.
Okay.
They use the sprint backbone and they rent time on it and then give you the same
service that you would get of yet sprint,
but at a very reasonable rate.
How reasonable.
I'm glad you asked ours.
Your fear,
how 98% of people would save money with Tang.
That's a lot of God damn people.
That's almost like saying everybody 98% it's just too fucking Weirdos that
somehow or another have strange data usage and they wouldn't save money.
Tina,
Tina has,
the way to set up is you only pay for what you use,
which I think is what the whole world is going to have to do in the future
because just like you used to have to pay for long distance.
If you called your friend in New York,
you remember that that is out the window now.
They had to abandon them.
They still got that.
Canada's still has that.
I have a joke.
Didn't work.
Oh,
this guy asking about his cell phone and second,
it's not long distance.
I'm like,
wait,
it's never long distance.
Oh,
they had a candidate.
What do you mean?
They also have socialized medicine.
You gotta take the good with the bad pros and cons,
pros and cons.
Um,
but what they do is they only charge you for what you use.
So because of that,
like you don't have like a lot of people that will have a plan a hundred minutes
or whatever the hell it is.
A lot of times you use way less than that,
especially with phone calls.
Who the fuck makes phone calls anymore?
Or probably way less phone calls than you?
You would just a few years ago because people tech soap so much,
but you oftentimes don't use all your minutes,
but you don't get credit for those.
And Ting used to do that now they used to give you credit,
but now they said,
you know what?
We got a better way to do this.
It's just pay for what you fucking use.
Oh really?
No early termination fees,
no cancellation fees.
Pay for what you get and use it while you're paying for it.
Hits.
I was hitting the game of spades.
Jesus fucking Christ someone get it right.
They also have the best android phones that you could buy.
All the cool ones,
all the fascinating new gadgets.
Um,
they have,
uh,
the uh,
Samsung Galaxy s three,
they have that,
that modot modot Max that we were talking about.
They have a,
that LG g flex galaxy
s five galaxy note three is what I meant to say.
And that HTC,
the HTC one,
the m eight,
which is pretty fucking slick.
A lot of really cool shit.
All the best and most groovy new cell phones.
And if you use rogan.ting.com,
you can save yourself $25 off any new phone,
rogan.ting.com.
All right,
Arash fears here.
This is what we call a pod cast debt park us debt.
So we will do an abbreviated version of the commercials.com is the size of most
people's pulled podcasts.
Fuck them.
People give you music.
Yon Jamie,
two Oh nine breaths.
What happens in Brian's not here.
The whole place goes to shit.
Look at you showing tin can run all night.
Know what the fuck your train.
And then the night comes and he's got it right.
Get it right.
You Ready?
Did you get it right?
All fucked up.
Oh,
you're a mass.
But can the folks here us.
Okay.
Well,
okay,
we don't need that music.
We were just having the music wants today.
Yeah.
We probably,
we got greedy.
Tried to,
to double music.
It can't do that.
It's not two for Tuesday.
Ours you fear as so many stories about China.
We talked about so many other things besides the stories about China,
which side we have to keep going.
So you were about to tell some crazy noodle story.
Oh yeah.
So they had these street meat,
which is great.
And this is Shanghai.
That's me.
I knocked into this table.
I was like,
it sounded like a fucking truck fell over outside.
Uh,
yeah.
Shanghai.
But uh,
they were like,
be careful there meets great.
You just,
there's kebabs.
You pick it up,
they roast it,
give it back to you.
The 0.3,
two,
whatever it is,
um,
for how much money you can get by with gesturing.
I learned hello and thank you.
Those are the only words I really do.
Huh?
Know,
I know that Ni Hao Kailand to show my kids watch Kylie.
Yeah,
that's cool.
That's crazy.
I can let her stuff.
Yeah.
So That's,
we say shush.
Shush,
Shush.
It's like thank you.
Ah,
okay.
That's also used some other way,
but I don't know.
So how do you,
um,
gesturing,
I got sick at gesturing really except a couple of times I would like big about
to go into like a noodle store or something like,
like a shop and I have to call my friend.
They gave you burner phones,
which is nice.
I could use and was like,
hey,
how do you say noodles and how do you say beef?
And I tell her both words.
I'm just go in.
I'd be like,
what?
What was it?
I forgot.
Now,
man,
man is noodles.
And uh,
one of the guys from the Matrix movie is the word for beef.
Who's the black guy from the Matrix?
Morpheus.
Okay.
What's the main guy?
His neo.
Neo,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's how you say beef
and was the other one.
That was the noodles man.
Same Yen Yao or neo and I don't know,
but I said that and then they're like,
they pointed the fucking menu.
Like there's 18 things.
I'm like,
lady,
come on,
you can see me struggling with if I'm,
and I come in and go beef noodle,
just pick something for him.
Listened to and just make something new saying this,
the amazing racist where if you would be like [inaudible]
you fuck
other parodies sketches.
Sure.
Yeah.
Horse.
It doesn't really feel that way ladies and gentlemen.
The comments on those are the best parts about it.
I got so angry you for those comments with the best.
Yeah.
Little man argue back and forth.
It still goes angry,
angry fuck heads.
So the noodles,
so they have these noodles is treat noodles you can get and I was advised the
first day like you don't want those and why someone's video that I can send you
right now.
You can put up,
oh,
but they are here.
Put your,
put your email in here and then just send it to me.
I said,
you can just send it to yourself,
but uh,
so the get the oil,
what they would do is they would go to the sewer,
they would take raw sewage out of the sewer and then boil it down.
The way they'd make wax hash wax,
they'd boil off the sewage and whatever was left.
That's cooking oil that they would use.
It's super fucking harmful and it sell to like a lot of the street noodle guys.
Yeah.
That face is what I made that same phase.
They were cooking with sewer oil,
Bro.
It was going around.
So it's not common,
but it was possible.
So it's not like that's the only way they do it.
No,
but the street places where like you run a risk here,
it's cheaper oil.
All mine,
there's got that source.
Oh my God,
what is this?
China's food production of course.
Gimme some gutter oil making of gutter oil.
Gimme some volume.
Jamie,
Jesus Christ.
Thanks all in a day's work for this woman.
She opens up a manhole cover and scoops out as much slop as she can.
Delighted by what she finds.
What's tell this might view is revolting.
She sees as a bonanza,
works in the streets at the southern Chinese city of Shenzhen,
a foot soldier in China,
so called Gutter oil industry.
Oh
my,
seriously.
Almost through swaps.
Gagged.
She says she's made enough money to build a house for her family back in her
home.
Village miles to the north.
People are just awful.
She's scooping out to up.
Eventually winds up in a processing plant like this one where it's combined with
other animal fat.
Refuse to create recycled cooking.
Oil workers put the oil in barrels for delivery to restaurant four days.
How can you eat this?
If you eat it,
it can kill you.
Cooking oil has long been a cherished commodity in China.
What's the frying in a walk is the mainstay of daily meal preparation.
The high profit margins from gutter oil production of Provan irresistible
Chinese experts estimate that one 10th of China's cooking law is gutter oil,
which has been found to contain carcinogens and other toxins harmful for humans.
You think water is bad for you?
Breaking news and among street food vendors of production sites often discovered
after people living nearby notice or nauseating stench and alert the
authorities.
It's really cooking your food.
Police have arrested scores of people across the country in recent years through
engaging in the trade and sees thousands of tons of the material.
Look at these guys,
fake the Chinese,
drawing it out a little bit.
Fairly harsh penalties for producers of tainted products,
but many consumers doubt that China's dinner tables can be completely free of
guttural.
All we can do as accepted in our current society,
everybody tries to swindle everybody else.
There's nothing we can do about wow.
Yeah,
that's a Fox gusting.
What that takes discussing to whole new level.
I have never pouring it from the bucket.
You hear the go get that sound bite?
No.
Does that too.
I almost threw up.
I had to look away.
That's the first time I've ever had to look away on a show.
Really?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Cause you knew where I was headed to someone's food,
Dude.
I almost threw up watching that,
so I did not have any of the street noodles.
I did have a lot of noodles though.
Oh my gosh.
Street noodles motherfucker man.
But that you might've had some gutter oil.
Absolutely.
I absolutely might've hot.
So what the fuck man,
I would like to know if you had got her oil.
I probably forgot to assume when I see that when it said where it was like I
probably had some gutter oil.
I would like to know how do you think we could find out when my friend was there
said it was like yeah I'm going to an eight it for a little while.
You know I got an a kick of eating it this way before the expos they came out
had a lot of diarrhea and it was a lot because you're eating shit cause you're
eating someone else's shit.
That guy we boil it,
we put a flame under it is to me,
you know what it's like when you,
when you see like the worst case scenarios about China and like then did you
ever see that HBO documentary about sitting them selling bay?
I think it was HBO.
There were selling children like Oh God,
guys were selling like their two year old children.
This one boy with screaming cause his dad sold his brother away.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Deep Dark Shit.
And they were interviewing the guy who sold his kid and he was like,
look,
I didn't have any money.
I had a kid,
I had a the kid.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's really fucked up.
I mean really fucked up.
But to me when I see stuff like that,
when I see that guy that was saying that,
you know people swindle people when it,
you see the whole gutter oil thing,
it's like humanity.
If it,
she gets bad if people were in a basket but people go bad,
they go real bad.
I compartmentalize.
They don't like this.
I'm not concerned with who gets those.
Like they just don't think about it like that.
I'm sure it's okay.
That lady was telling me I have bought a house.
You bought a house by feeding people shit.
How much shit did you have to shovel to get your house?
And you have to continue shoveling shit in order to pay for that house.
I assume they have mortgages over there.
Do they have mortgages?
She's not buying a house with cash,
like showing up.
I don't think so.
Big fucking stack of paper,
Dude.
That's insane.
That was critic growth.
That's beyond gross.
I almost threw up on a podcast.
I'm never done that before.
That thick plopping sound to die hosted fear factor.
For instance.
I've seen some shit.
I'm not a regular person in that regard.
I seen more disgusting shit than almost any other person who's a comedian.
Yeah.
Up Close and person right there and helped people get through eating.
Never.
And I got nauseous from that smell the shit.
Put it up.
That sound made.
It's though descriptive.
Yeah.
The block.
I really,
I got that weird tingle in my throat.
I know controller.
Oh,
what is horrible.
Yeah.
Brian Calvin told me he was in China and uh,
they were at a restaurant and the restaurant had pigs underneath the restaurant
and running around.
Yeah.
They were liking containers underneath the restaurant and they realized,
his mom asked and realize that when you shit the shit was going down to where
the pigs,
where the pigs are eating your shit.
Human Shit.
Oh gross.
And then you're being [inaudible] even the pigs mother fucker.
That's unfortunate.
You think,
I mean and they're doing it old school style.
You're shitting in a hole.
You're squatting like you were talking about in the first podcast before this
one where you're talking about podcasts.
We did.
Yeah,
we did another podcast couple,
couple of hours ago.
Um,
Ari was talking about how you'd go into these bathrooms and there's a hole in
the ground that's your toilet.
So underneath that whole pigs,
just wait and see.
That's how fucking good.
But again,
that's what happens when people just get,
when it goes bad,
play that noise again.
Jamie,
don't do it.
Just play that noise alone.
Don't do it.
That's that part.
Just queue it up.
And kids,
we knew all her,
all
that Plop,
plop,
plop is there.
The hashish in a Hong Kong was cut with up to up to 25% gutter oil.
Nope.
Shoe Polish through hard percentage for me,
but there wasn't California weed there.
25% show up to up to God damn.
Just because they want it to make it big.
Make it make more.
God damn that's so grow kind of looks like shoe Polish.
Tell us you can't really tell.
Yeah man.
It's fucking me up.
Like,
yeah,
it's not good.
We'd show.
Imagines just fucking you up.
What does Hash Cup with shoe Polish smell like?
I don't know.
It's got to have us Turpin tiny service smell to it.
You know that smell,
you know those cans.
You'd open up your grandpa's shoe Polish and you smell it.
It's,
yeah,
there was a little,
you know and it was like those little circular cans.
I keep it moist or something.
I don't know.
I'm saying,
I'm saying to you,
this signs the circular ones.
I know.
Maybe we shine on shabbos shoes with us.
Yes.
Spit spit on a rock.
Yeah,
just rub it on there.
We had the ones brushes too,
where you can use an old smart though,
like do you see those guys at the airport now?
Like shoe shiners,
the shoe shine guys,
but that's,
you never see those anywhere else.
It's the airport and that's it.
They come around business businesses.
Sometimes in New York they'll go door to d c to this guy used to come to like
art or law firm or he would go like each business like once a week.
Have you ever seen one in La at a business?
I mean it must be so I'm going,
am I in a business?
Why now?
Are you in a business?
You know what I mean?
In an office building,
whenever you're a in your fucking apartment,
you were in a business.
That's the beautiful thing about being a comic.
Yeah,
I got some technically in my business or you're in the business of writing
fucked up things down.
They will eventually become jokes.
That's a business.
Might not be your business,
but it's a fucking ned to the,
to the,
to the heat on it's business.
I'm a beat off on myself and watch cartoon in my computer with me.
Some research
cause it right off.
This is right off time.
I'm hoping that he watching all this porn,
I can come up with a joke about me watching all this porn and if not so be it to
have shit.
Yeah.
That's the beautiful thing about being a comic at anything you're interested in.
Like anything you pursue online could potentially be a ball research.
Yeah.
You could mean literally anything,
any idea that you read online that you find fascinating,
you can find.
If it strikes you,
you can find a comic angle to it.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Exactly.
Anything you care about enough to look at.
And it's almost like today we're spoiled because every day there's some new
ridiculous story that goes on.
It could be like an awesome bit and they just keep flying by
and they're like,
oh no guys,
don't forget about the story because I'm already doing a bit about it.
Well,
you even if people forget about it,
you can re you know the idea,
but the idea is that you forget about them because there's so many of another
one comes by.
Just all constantly retweeting things where I'm like,
what?
Like I'll retweet it and go,
I got to write a bit about that,
but it's,
it just goes,
it goes by the wayside because it's just too much shit.
There's so much.
If you look online,
like if you have a bunch of good Twitter feeds that you follow,
you'll find some of the most ridiculous articles to store.
A guy got a new lot know fucking American tourist got to cotton,
a giant vaginas statute in Germany.
He had a rescue,
the billboard for that.
Another billboard preview.
Nope.
Lab site has a lot of things.
The headline,
just the one word,
the tops top of that.
What the US student is rescued from a giant vagina sculpture in Germany.
You find it on my Twitter feed there too.
They laugh at us.
How stupid.
We are.
Dumb as fuck.
They let us look at this fucking giant vagina.
Yeah.
He's got his legs trapped in there,
fucking idiot.
The firemen had to kind and get them out.
What do you step in?
And then they should have just hacked his legs off with an ax.
It,
she came over,
left leg,
the leg in there.
She just grabbed the ax and he would have figured out a way to get out.
No,
no,
no.
Wait,
I'm sorry.
I called nine one one.
Sorry.
Hack.
Chop,
chop.
Just let me try to get my right leg out.
No,
no.
Chop Chop.
I realize.
Not even stuck though.
Let me just shut up.
Shop.
Yeah,
the vagina sculpture.
First of all,
why do you have a vagina sculpture?
Germany.
You fucking Weirdos.
Like what is that about?
Germany.
Mozambique.
What an odd choice to have a fucking vagina sculpture outside.
But me.
Meanwhile,
vaginas are fucking super important.
Yeah,
they're inviting.
Yeah.
If it wasn't for Vaginas,
there'd really be no people.
Of course we're supposed to get inside it.
But isn't that funny that for whatever reason,
like it's a bad time to have a vagina sculpture.
You can have a sculpture of a woman's face.
Yep.
That's no problem.
No problem.
No controversy.
Controversy,
shoulders,
showing the boob off man boobs get tricky with those.
Cover the boobs.
As long as the boobs are colored and you're an angel,
that's okay.
You're an angel.
Forget about it.
And Angel thing like that.
Your town square but a vagina.
That's when I don't like that.
It looks like a vagina to,
if you scroll down Jamie,
there's a picture of this fucking poor slob was goofy glasses.
Yeah.
This headline was it poor slob gets stuck in a statue.
Look at this vagina statue.
What's that?
You find the image?
I found foot.
The more photos of it.
Oh this fucking crazy bitch got so far down.
It's so stuffed into this thing that he couldn't move his legs like they had to
figure out how to get him out of that thing.
We don't play that.
Just show that.
Just go to photos cause this is the kind of shit that gets us kicked off of
Youtube.
Yeah,
he go,
there he is.
Oh Wow.
Look at this.
Fuck the eyes is another one with its face.
We should shame him,
so,
oh wow.
So He fell over or something and then he couldn't claim like an idiot and he's
like,
he's got smushed.
He got stuck or it's a gag.
It could be a stunt because that looks pretty tight in his legs though.
It does,
but so does he always got to put everything up like it's possible as a stunt.
Yeah,
always.
It looks like it.
If I had to guess,
it looks like it's thought.
Yeah,
he's 22 firefighters had to pry him open.
Oh my God.
Wow.
22 firefighters.
They probably got jerked off on him to lube it up.
That'd be great.
No magic.
There's only one way to do this.
We've got to jerk off on my legs.
That's the only way you up his legs.
It's fucking Americans.
What does it feel like telling people in another country like China that you're
American?
Do they just go,
oh well the other Chinese people,
you didn't really talk too much.
You didn't talk to them much.
Barely.
The only thing was the spoken English.
You hanging out with the Chinese ladies?
Yeah.
One bump,
bump bump.
I'm Brown.
She was at this bar that I like,
that's I performed that are like right next door in this area.
Um,
I thought she was in my show,
but then later I wasn't positive.
Apparently they have a thing according to this guy who posted on the Rogan
board,
he lives in China,
but they have a thing for people with big noses.
Oh really?
White white men with big noses.
Crazy for it because it looks so different to them.
Yeah.
She just sort of,
we didn't really talk English at all and we just sort of like,
you know,
a couple of words,
but then you got the vibe.
He's still a vibe there.
So he kind of knew.
Did you feel like you were like,
like some crazy foreigner,
like some savage from another land?
A little bit.
Tell me more.
Well,
that's the area,
but there's a lot of foreigners there.
Right?
Um,
so they got area Lan Kwai Fong,
this guy in the Rogan board was saying,
I should give the guy credit.
He was saying that,
um,
that these women that you'd have to tell them that you loved them.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but saying that you love like saying that is different doesn't mean it's like,
it doesn't mean that means I love you.
What does it mean?
Like what you think it means here?
Like people say it all.
There were differences like that.
Yeah.
And then he was also saying that when the breakout,
when you break up with them,
they go fucking crazy.
He was saying that you have,
he had a real problem with that.
You break up and they go crazy.
Yeah.
Like suicidal or murderous.
Oh really?
Yeah.
His name is ripple.
That's there.
The guys are very long thread.
Um,
and it's on the rogue aboard.
It's actually from July 23rd of 2010.
So it's a four year old thread and they just recently got a bumped up probably,
I mean maybe because of you being there.
Oh really?
That's cool.
Maybe,
maybe I'm wondering,
but it might just be coincidental,
but either way.
Pretty interesting shit.
This guy talking about his experiences being a white guy in China and just
dating chicks in heat.
He never was into Chinese checks until he went to China.
And then he got like super into them.
I'll probably there all the time.
They're not fat.
They're if they're all real thin,
like I took two thin,
almost too thin a lot of times.
Like you've got to have some meat on your bones.
No,
but so I would definitely no buts,
no buts were scarce.
That'd be a problem.
A lot of barbecue chicken clause
that that what he calls make tits.
He said that though the Chinese people that lived there that ate McDonald's grew
tits.
Wow.
Because of all the hormones is shot into it.
Fuck.
He said those were the ones.
It was like one of his,
one of his things that they're out the mic.
Tits theory be cups.
Ah,
Nice.
Big Up.
But you know,
nothing crazy man.
Tits.
That's funny.
Yeah.
And then interesting that the ones who ate a lot of Mcdonald's food.
So hilarious.
It's is a mic,
tits theory that the foreigners have formulated over their body type.
Wow,
isn't that crazy?
But if they live off Mcdonald's,
they have tits.
But he was saying that they mistake 40 year olds for 30 year olds or younger.
And I think I've heard some of them are like they're looking,
well a lot of times they're also like um,
immigrant workers that when they get off they just look at a fuck.
They're just looking to have a good time man.
I've never seen anybody party like that on Sundays.
They get off and they have very little rights and but Sundays you don't work and
they just fill up the markets and they all danced there all thought d like line
dancing together by the bay.
Achy breaky Rankin.
Yeah.
All sweet.
But like the Chinese music but absolutely.
They don't just know that there are things they party like they are free for one
day for one day.
Wow.
That's interesting.
So do you think they like they're all bottled up and then they get that one job
so they had just enjoy your life.
We're going to enjoy this.
We're going to enjoy our day off.
No one's taking a staycation.
Let's all get out there.
Some comics have daisy barbecues all the time and they get super lazy.
Yeah,
I forget to appreciate those days off.
You get used to it.
You Know Eddie Bravo always talks about that 80 bravo always talks about like
learning to appreciate life like that.
Sometimes in the middle of it it's really difficult to appreciate it and that
you got to like force yourself to like really appreciate it.
Really step back and appreciate how awesome this is.
Yeah.
Once in a while I'll get a new comic.
They'll be like,
like,
like genuinely like,
man,
you got your name on the wall at the comedy store.
That's so cool.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah.
I mean I guess so.
Did they take my name down?
No they don't.
No,
they don't take names down.
They should slide names.
You should take down.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's a fun bunch of fucking names where you go.
Come on man.
I thought it's got his name up there.
Fuck out of here.
If they would take those names down,
I wouldn't be mad if they took mine down.
Got To get off.
You can take mine that while you can take my down.
Anybody.
But the is up at twice as he really,
they thought he'd slipped through the cracks and they put them up aside another
time and then he didn't slip through the cracks.
But that's how late they are about not taking names down because they look
twice.
I'm like,
oh,
I guess it's up there.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So what if someone did something terrible?
Like what about that comic that was like a rapist?
Remember that comment rapist?
He was going to colleges and your name stays up.
Wow.
Is His name up there?
I don't know.
Maybe.
I don't know if he was,
I don't think he wasn't paid regular,
but I would have heard that if he was,
somebody would have run into him.
That's it's fuck I had his name and the tips of my tongue.
Yeah,
that guy's in jail forever.
Right?
Jail Joe from while.
Lot of rapes.
Lot of reps.
Creepy religious shit to them.
Like pray for me.
Oh really?
It's tell them to Vince champ.
That's it.
There it is.
Thanks.
Tip of tongue.
Yeah.
I remember not knowing who that guy was,
but the people that did know who that guy was,
we were like,
oh,
I could see that.
I'm like,
oh,
Adam Richmond just got acquitted.
Adam Richmond,
the food guy.
No,
no,
it's comic.
Oh my God,
who's an enrichment comic?
Scare the shit out of it.
I don't know why I'm scared of the Food Guy Getting raped or raping.
What happened?
There was something in Minneapolis Ou.
Yeah,
with the weight.
Someone accused him waitress.
Who Do you believe?
Uh,
well a lot of people find out in Richmond annoying.
So a lot of the comic community was like,
I could see,
I'm like,
that's not equal to sexual assault and knowing is not the same as sexual
assault.
Right.
But isn't annoying a sign of being a clueless fuck.
And he's includes fuckers sign of being selfish and isn't being selfish to type
of person.
He's fun.
Yeah.
He's also drunk.
And he said he was getting aggressive to the coffee.
He said it was getting a little aggressive and then they have like some nine on
one foot,
like video,
like not video,
audio of him like her.
Go on,
put your fucking Dick Away,
put your dick away.
We'll get outta here
but acquitted.
Wow.
And what did he do?
Well,
who cares?
What do we fucking TMZ.
Yeah,
but you know what man,
there's a real problem when you have sexual urges.
Yeah.
Idiots and alcohol,
all those things together as two,
it adds to it.
But also being an idiot,
you know you're not a sexual assaulter.
Yeah.
You know,
you wouldn't hold someone down and do something creepy to them if you were
drunk.
What time is John coming out with Amy curfew in college as a friend.
You're just kissing and stuff.
And I was like,
come on and try and get in her pants and she goes,
no,
like kissing was as far as it was going to go.
Right.
And the other come on,
she's like,
no,
come on,
stop.
Um,
and then I got up to like as a joke to like lock the door.
Like,
hey,
lock the door.
We're doing this.
And then as soon as I like to do,
I took one step back.
I'm like,
oh,
this seems like a door opened it up.
This seems right.
This is weird.
Why?
It's not even funny.
It's like,
yeah,
but we've all been in that situation where it girls like,
no,
and you're like,
please,
please.
Yeah,
but doesn't work sometimes.
Some guys are assholes.
What do you mean it doesn't work?
Sometimes it never works to beg for policy.
Sometimes does.
Oh,
and they just give it negative.
I've ever heard of the [inaudible] time when a girl says,
okay,
Oh yeah,
finally you can stop fighting.
Okay,
but only put it on my ass.
Yeah,
but you add like idiocy,
sexual urges and alcohol is a fucking terrible,
terrible,
terrible combination.
But it's everywhere.
That's the weirdest thing about people.
He's like the worst combination of drugs to dating is what you get.
I mean,
good in that it's a social lubricant.
People relax,
have a couple of drinks.
It loosens up the vibe.
You might get a little loose and silly and have fun and be more,
more likely to fool around,
but you know,
at a certain point you've got to realize that that's not everybody's,
like we were talking about earlier in the podcast,
that I don't know what happens to some people when they drink,
but I've seen it.
Yeah,
you see you see it.
Yeah.
You seen that switch that goes off and they're not there anymore.
It's not you.
You don't do that.
I don't do that.
But we all know guys who do do that.
One of them's got a portrait in the bathroom mirror.
It's one out of 10 you know,
whatever it is.
When you see that man,
you know that that guy shouldn't be drinking shoes around women if he has a
sexual urge.
Cause it's just going to be a disaster.
Yeah,
but that's the drug of choice.
That's what you get.
You could go to a bar,
you don't get an option.
You can take ecstasy.
Yeah.
Fuck Yak.
You imagine being a chick and dude,
you're trying to drug you.
Oh,
how many girls have you talked to that had been roofied Oh,
a lot right now.
All the ones I hung out with,
I don't know
all the ones I roofie but that doesn't count.
Just fucking bitches had a coffee drink it.
So you know,
the stats are all skewed.
It wasn't bill Cosby in trouble for some shit like that.
Really?
No doctor Cosby,
Bill Cosby.
Second only to Martin.
To the king and important black men.
Not really bill Cosby.
Sexual assault allegations.
Um,
uh,
why isn't anyone,
why doesn't anyone care about the sexual assault allegations against bill Cosby
allegations that people agree that like once a month famous enough,
we're just not going to care.
Yeah,
I don't know man.
I mean,
who the fuck knows it's true.
It also could be just,
you know,
it's,
who knows the girl,
the comedy store claim somebody raped her and one of the door guys and we've got
really weird for a while cause you don't really know who to believe.
But at the same time it's like this is bad.
You're not gonna come out vehemently on,
I'm inside of the door guy.
You know,
you might be like,
I'm not gonna get involved.
And then a few months later she accused someone else or raping her.
Uh,
and then like eight months after that she accused the third person and
everything.
I was like,
why do you keep hanging out at the rape house?
I'm starting to believe that maybe there's none of this happened.
Yeah.
Well that was,
um,
the guy,
the girl who claimed that Mike Tyson raped her.
Yeah.
She had made a false allegation or she was 18 about another guy.
I feel like,
I think either through it Mike Michael Tyson was,
that wasn't a good conviction.
Um,
he probably did a bunch of bad shit,
but in that situation,
yeah,
it seems like that girl went back up to his room wanting to fuck.
She took her panty liner off.
I don't know what happened.
I don't want to speculate because I wasn't there.
You know what the fuck knows?
But there's a lot of shit going on when,
when you have someone who's got a false allegation,
it's like the problem is do players,
they all lost their seats worse.
It's way worse to rape someone than it is to falsely accuse someone of rape.
In my opinion,
it's worse because the rape is a violent crime,
falsely accusing someone of rape,
although horrific in my id and my hierarchy of crimes is slightly lower.
What if the same amount of violence happened to you because of Dan?
It's the same crime.
Like if you go to jail and then guys rape you because you with the punishment
for rape is,
is it just the punishment?
If it's like,
okay,
that's about right.
You know,
like the eight months of his personality and like that's too,
that's too much.
Whoa,
whoa.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
13 women said Kylie,
she's bill Cosby drugging them
with what?
Um,
Jello.
Oh
my God.
13.
That's a lot.
This is insane.
Where there's smoke,
there's 13 fires.
Wow,
that's amazing.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
I mean who knows what the fuck happened,
but uh,
you know,
and I don't want to be callous about it.
I'm not,
I'm just saying who knows,
cause I don't know,
but I don't look good.
Be Callin about it.
Brian.
Cosby's cock.
Cause listen,
understand seemed in the sun hawks with land on it,
you know,
he makes its own Ruthie's,
you don't even understand it.
They weren't drugged.
They were fuck to sleep.
You're big calendar about it.
Catlin.
I like that.
That's a dude's there,
right?
Yeah.
Joey keys would probably say a similar thing.
Bill Cosby drugging and those bitches,
he just gives him that sweet thick candy,
Jello Pudding Cup and pop.
Uh,
that's not a good amount of,
that's not a good number.
I almost saw him recently.
I went really?
Yeah.
They were telling.
Everybody keeps telling me,
you gotta go see him live.
You've got to go see him live.
It'd be their first experience of like,
it was a fun childhood.
Like well also they say it's really good people shitting on a special and people
are like,
how can you show it?
Especially as legend.
Like cause we're not shitting on his,
on his legacy was shitting on this one special.
That's how you can say everything he does is good now.
He's definitely a good,
he's definitely a great artist.
As far as like his,
the bulk of his stand up comedy history.
He's a million right now.
Great guys.
He's not perfect.
He's a great,
great comedian for the longest time.
Yeah.
I didn't watch his new one that I watched a little bit of it on comedy central
and I never got a chance to see in Vegas.
I was with too many people too scared.
Scared to go see it live.
To know to watch the camera central thing because you'd hate it.
I got enough respect for him.
I don't need to wash it.
Yeah.
But do you have more or less respect for him if he drug 14 chicks,
that seems,
that seems like if it's special sucks,
that's not nearly as disappointing.
It's like you gotta be more honest on stage if that's what you're gonna really
do.
You got to deal with that from your act.
Could you imagine if like,
he's like the squeaky clean guy,
but really just dirty in life.
It's rugging chicks and like that prices.
Right.
And that price is right.
We'll show is that family feud?
What did he do?
The height cameras.
Wasn't that movie height?
Oh,
no,
no.
Hogan's heroes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The other guy who is on the hug and tears was the host of family feud went on
to,
I remember
the British combs.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no before him.
Oh,
really?
Shy.
Yeah.
I don't remember.
Oh yeah,
I remember that guy.
The original guy?
Yeah.
He was the original guy.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Who the fuck was his name is?
What was that dude's name?
Jamie.
Awesome.
Richard Dawson.
Dawson would always kiss the luck and ladies.
Yeah,
I remember he was in Hogan's heroes.
That's why cause ladies,
because he was selfish to fucking horn.
They were just fi's evidence from our movie.
That's him.
Yeah.
Richard Dawson.
So he's a British POW.
Yeah,
that's right.
Look at him slinging Dick would that fucking beautiful vest on.
I got a suit made with a three piece.
Like I saw,
I saw you.
I retweeted it.
Your pimp ass photos from,
no,
I retweeted you a Po.
Bruce Lee won the day.
That one got the most like favorites.
I've ever gotten through to that.
What were you doing to his dick?
And it was like the rod and I just like angled it.
So I was like right in his dick that's in Hong Kong.
That was in Hong Kong.
He's,
he liked the biggest star to ever come out of Hong Kong International,
I believe so managing the other Chinese dudes like,
what the fuck do I have to do?
This doesn't make any sense to guys ever jet Li and him.
That's it.
Oh Jackie Chan,
whatever.
Three guys.
And one guy was like,
I invented tables.
I can't get a fucking footnote.
Oh look at you balling.
It was because he's made it.
How long did that take?
Either go once they've measured you pick out a fabric.
They measure you.
Rhodes told me about it.
They love him.
His headshots on the wall there
has been there for 30 years.
Rocky,
the guy on the left.
Wow.
Your left or his uh,
yeah,
that guy though.
The guy to be a blue shirt.
Yeah.
Rocky.
Yeah,
30 years.
How old is he?
Looks like he's 80 he's like 60 something.
So He's been there since she was 30 son's there other guys been through it a bit
on Taylor and for like 45 years he had to pick out a fabric.
They measure you and then you come back the next day to like to like measure on
your body,
like see what they got to take in and stuff and you come back a couple days
later,
pick up a suit.
That's what they did for me for the UFC.
All of you'll find like told you like we're going to do this for you.
Yeah,
they gave up on me handmade suit.
They just made it for,
yeah.
Great.
Thank you.
It won't fit better than that.
It's Kinda tight.
It is.
Yeah.
I stopped wearing the jacket.
The jacket is too much.
I'm just a,
they don't make them for chimpanzees and make them for regular people and get it
made for your fucking garbage.
Cam does a body type.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't.
The jacket doesn't work.
The close work fine.
Although they're a little tight.
It's weird.
It's like a stretchy fabric so it doesn't feel bad that it's tight.
Yeah.
Moves real good.
But you know,
it's like there's like a slim look that people wearing these days.
Slim Trim and sort of passels people like in like the lower east side where I'm
like,
God damn you look good.
It's like a one button and like fuck.
Yeah man.
Like fucking cool suits.
Like cheese,
like suits,
chicks,
that shit walking around those stupid shoes on.
They like that.
Oh yeah,
the stupid shoes.
Slippery,
uncomfortable,
slippery shoes.
This is so ridiculous.
They tried to get me to where those,
the slipper shoes.
I'm like,
bitch,
why you never been filmed my feet?
I should wear sneakers.
He's wear ratty.
Chuck Taylor's good move shit.
But occasionally to see my feet.
So how you do that with bottom up?
Like I'm trying too hard.
Oh yeah.
You know like if you're a comedian you wear chuck Taylors with a nice suit.
Jordan Ruben.
But it's like you're being a comedian,
you're trying too hard.
You're like,
look,
I'm wacky.
I'm a wacky guy.
I had a meeting with a dude once.
There was a time,
I don't know if I told you the story.
This is a time where they were giving out development deals,
like fucking crazy,
left and right.
Mad Money,
mad money for comedians and more importantly for writers.
And this one guy was a writer,
he was a writer on like friends and he got a crazy deal,
a crazy,
and it was like,
I think it was Michael Eisner's company and we're going to add some comp company
and an office and they say,
we got you for two years.
Give us some ideas.
Yeah.
And so I had a development deal with Fox at the time,
so they wanted me to meet with this cat.
So a,
I met with this guy to,
uh,
work on a sitcom.
This is post news radio right after news radio ended,
I got this development deal done with us.
You got to tell another story.
So I go tell another story.
Yeah.
Okay.
You gotta tell me what it is you're writing down.
So I go,
um,
freaked me out.
What was I talking about?
It's got this development too.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So I go in this guy's office,
um,
and they gave him this giant fucking development dealer.
Tell me how amazing he is.
One of the writers on friends guys.
Incredible.
It turns out he was actually a partner of a funny guy and he was the guy who
would write shit down and they're just like a two guy team and this guy got a
development deal but he was horrible.
So I go in to meet with him and he's wearing bowling shoes and I looked down and
I see those bowling shoes.
Why does that work?
Oh he's a wacky guy who wears bowling shoes cause he's silly,
don't you get it?
So this guy is like talking to me about plot and this and that and I'm looking
at his bowling shoes.
You silly silly mother.
And I got out of there,
Sussman said the same thing to me.
He goes,
you see a serious,
I was just wearing bowling shows and I go,
yeah,
what's up with that?
And he goes,
he's,
he's trying to once you to think he's wacky.
Oh like who likes wacky crystal bumble,
wacky guy.
Cause he was thinking like that's how you become a funny guy.
You've got to walk around with bowling shoes on.
The script that he wrote was such a massive hunk of shit.
Oh essentially it was about an immortal guy and the mortal guy who bang chicks,
he,
he like got cursed in Egypt and bank checks through the end of time,
like t to the future and had all these sexual dilemmas.
It was like weird.
It was so bad.
It was so,
it didn't make any sense.
It was like you would read it and you would go,
who could have thought this was funny.
I was in the office with the Fox people when they brought it to me and you know
they have this like,
did you like,
did you read it?
And so we have this meeting.
I go,
yeah,
did you read it?
Oh yeah,
I go,
I fucking told you.
I like I told you.
And they're like,
well I mean it's important what?
He's really good at his story structure.
I go,
what the fuck do you mean by that?
You just said nonsense.
What?
He's really good as story structure.
The idea is that like maybe you comedians know how to make things laugh,
make people laugh.
But what you don't know is how to structure a story.
Like nobody really cares about the structure and the story when they say stuff
like that.
Like story structure.
You know what they did just sing words
mean.
So I'll just say it through an argue with me.
Well there's guys who know how to write movies or books that are really
good.
Good story structure.
Cash,
right?
24.
Yeah.
That's hardest shit.
Hardest Shit.
Really good at structuring stories.
He spent a ton of time on it,
but a sick comments about being funny stories are important but funny stories or
like Larry David was the master of that,
you know,
cause he would,
you knew how to make a funny third through line.
It's funny though.
The idea at itself,
he's hilarious.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I want to follow audition for some,
for some part I told you this but I read it,
you know,
some best friend character and a,
the casting director was like,
um,
okay.
Uh,
I was good.
My only note,
you didn't do any of the lines.
You told me this.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
the blinds,
it's terrible.
I can't,
I cannot do those.
I was supposed to go off of that same role.
That's hilarious.
I read it and I was like,
get the fuck Outta here.
They're making a big push through the comedian community.
I got to me and I was like,
cause I'm not,
I'm not completely out of the loop.
I don't audition for things,
I don't want to act.
I don't have any desires.
So when it comes to me,
it's coming to me completely out of the blue.
Like I don't know,
I don't put myself out in that world.
The only person I've ever acted with is Kevin James.
Cause we're friends in the last decade plus.
So I was like,
well maybe it's just really good.
You read it.
It's like I ain't could.
And then I heard what you did and I was like,
that's,
that's how they handle it.
I said yes before I read it.
So now kind of fuck around.
How fun or so I just not go like,
why do you want me to handle it?
I don't want to get you in trouble with the cousin Garth.
And she goes,
Ari,
I'm never going to tell you not to do what you want to do.
Wow.
It's good agent.
Yeah,
but that's how they make a piece of Shit Sitcom near.
Just wonder how you took a funny guy.
Make a fucking terrible sitcom with them.
So I'll come up with some shitty writer who just whips it out in a week.
It doesn't care about it at all.
Some dickhead wearing bowling shoes thinking is wacky.
Oh
well that's the beautiful thing about being a comic,
about detaching yourself from that ridiculous system.
Like for the longest time we were all taught that we had to get a sitcom.
You what you want to do to get a second.
I mean I have to go to put together an act,
get,
get your seven minutes.
I just want to go on the road.
Just that's the only way you're gonna go on the road and have a draw.
Put a,
put a say come together.
That was the thing,
man,
that's what we owe.
We always were taught that and then suddenly you're like,
I just lost faith in television.
Like I stopped even caring.
It was like a girl you're trying to fuck all the time.
She doesn't want to fuck you after a,
it's like I'm not even mad at you.
I just,
you're irrelevant.
I just stopped thinking about you.
Well,
one thing that I,
oh Dane Cook yeah,
for sure is that Dane Cook inspired me to use social media more do this without,
without the TV that the approval of some guy.
Well,
he inspired me to um,
to use like social media in a promotion where I never used it before,
but I saw the results that he got,
which were insanely good.
My space mean he got results from performances for sure,
but he also got results.
The fact that
he had so many myspace friends,
he capitalizes on those results of the shows that capitalize so hard on them.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
Completely fascinating.
So that got me really into my space,
which got me really into Twitter,
which got me,
I'd always had a message board.
But that's also when Brian and I started working together and he started
creating videos and that also nice.
But it's not the same.
But I,
yeah,
it's not the same that the message board is very exclusive,
exclusive,
but you know,
limited.
But once you see,
he showed the way a little bit where it's like,
guys,
we don't need them anymore.
Well,
some of it are on.
He was the first guy to break through.
And when I saw it I was like,
I was looking at what he created by,
by breaking through like that now.
And then I started seeing,
I was like,
Ooh,
there's gonna come a point in time.
Maybe it's now,
maybe it's in the future where all it's going to matter is how many people you
can connect with online.
Like what,
whatever you can create that people,
whether it's one of those videos that Brian used to do or whether it's a blog
entry or whether it's a standup comedy clip or whether it's a podcast,
which didn't even exist back then,
but I have a podcast called skeptic.
Everyone should check it out.
It's pretty fun.
But that was one of the things that led us to doing those Justin.
Dot TV,
those justice.
The first kind of podcasts we did turn on the green room.
We used to do these.
I used to have a thing that connected to my laptop that would like stream the
internet from my,
from like a cell phone.
It's a long time ago.
Oh yeah.
We did have wifi and like the the cops green room.
Oh it was a long time ago.
It was one cell phone data was first starting to make an its way to laptops with
like this little USB things and then they started making some like thinkpads and
some certain cell phone or some certain laptops that had cellular connections
built into them.
So they had a Wifi cellular data.
Like I have an iPad that's a Verizon iPad.
It's sinked up to Verizon,
so even if there's no Wifi,
I can still get on.
I could still like,
wow.
You know,
look at websites and shit like that.
I love it.
It's really cool.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Yeah,
it's nice.
It's,
it's,
it's way better than like trying to look at something on your phone.
You can look at it on your why on your Ipad,
you know?
It's like a real website,
but back then when we were in that room and we were doing it,
were streaming it from that little clunky USB thing that would stick in there,
that start,
I'll start it off because they didn't cook.
He wasn't doing that at the time.
He wasn't doing that,
but he did something online that I thought it was extraordinary.
I tell comics too,
I'm like,
when they're like,
ah,
sort of private,
let's go to Paul.
I was like,
it might not be big and it's almost definitely won't,
but keep doing things to move forward.
You'll get a couple of fans.
Yeah,
but it's not going to be at one mass.
It could easily be big if it's good.
Beautiful thing about podcasts is that it's about merit.
Like look at Joey Diaz.
Perfect example.
Joey Diaz is not famous for anything other than being awesome.
It all came from him being awesome.
It didn't come from movies.
It didn't come from TV shows,
didn't come from anything else and they did a lot of those things,
did all those things.
Joey Diaz got famous for doing podcasts from people realizing what a funny
fucking guy he is just for being awesome and that that wasn't available.
Man.
When I,
when,
when Dane Cook popped out of the scene,
that was when I first became aware like,
Whoa,
the Internet isn't just for looking at stuff.
It's,
they're putting stuff out.
I love what you don't need anybody's approval [inaudible] stuff.
Give us your fans,
give it to whoever.
They can't take that back to them.
It's over and the way we use it is very unique too because we all support each
other and we tweet each other shit and we pump each other up.
We,
we do shows together like you meet Dunkin Diaz,
red band,
Eddie Bravo,
everybody's all connected in this little thing.
And because of that,
because of that connection,
it's like,
it makes like for an even bigger force,
like an even bigger impact,
you know,
like Tripoli's fucking CD was number two on iTunes.
So happy.
He was so happy it was mouth for like a week and a half.
Yeah.
Like a whole week and a half.
Or happy.
Super happy.
And also he sees the light at the end of the tunnel.
You know,
it's something like that happens.
I can get a little bit of like fucking headlines all over the place in the road.
Now.
He did Edmonton,
we did Edmonton the week before.
He did,
uh,
the River Creek Casino with me and then he went back and got comedy club the
next week.
Yeah,
I was wondering that the first couple times I did it with you,
but it wasn't like the next week,
but it was like within some time and I'm like,
well,
hell,
it's called the club owner.
Make sure they're okay with it because we already had this thing booked,
you know?
But then a couple of them,
it's okay.
And then you realize you're telling way more people.
Yeah.
It's a lot of people will just come back and you're going to kill in front of
those 2000 people at the river Cree and they're going to tell them all.
We went to see this guy,
Ari Shaffir.
Holy Shit.
Was He funny?
Oh my God,
he's at the comedy club.
Next time if you get 30 people extra shelves,
they were like,
thank you so much.
Here's some extra money.
They're so happy when a club like that that's consistently gets good people like
Brian Cowen was there.
We were on the plane and uh,
Adam Hunter was there.
Yeah.
I was going up to Edmonton a couple of weeks ago and I ran into a hunter on a
plane.
Oh,
that was for the hunting?
Yeah,
the hundred minutes.
Yeah.
And Hunter was up there doing that comedy club.
Kallan was there to,
we hunter was up there.
No Adam Hunt out of mind or the comedian just got the hunter.
I had up to five minutes.
Yeah,
I've heard it's a great club that's owned by the same people who talked me out
of jail time at mall of America.
Pretty hilly.
Yeah.
They talked you out of it.
That got you.
Uh,
yeah.
When I was,
when I,
when I did the high,
the edible they,
so they allegedly was a really hot,
the edibles fan.
Right.
We're not on trial a government man.
I'm concerned.
I'm concerned about the future.
I had a conversation with someone about this today,
someone who was talking about um,
medical marijuana and marijuana being legal in Colorado and you know,
cause I was just legal so I'll pop around.
It's in the Rockies games.
So look for authentic woo.
Amazing,
right?
Yeah.
And then incredible.
I'm so worried about 2016 why?
Because of a couple things.
The conversation went like this.
We were talking about all this shit that's going down in Iraq and I,
that if I rack it's really ugly and things started happening like really bad.
And then someone blames Obama and they blame Democrats and they blame weakness
switching over this time and then we'll will just tell us about with Obama.
So Hillary doesn't have a chance can go Jeb Bush style and then I could go John
Ashcroft style and then that same type of thinking.
I was like Chris Christie style that tries to like medical marijuana will never
be legal in my state.
Marijuana,
we never leave a little mystery.
Children are losing,
they're dying out there.
They're parking.
Brains are rotting,
their feet are exploding inside their shoes,
their dicks or fallen off the these guys,
they're all like in that sort of vein.
Like when he,
when Chris Christie in 2000 fucking 14 it's spreading.
Misinformation is a guy who's,
what is he just crazy shit about cannabis and the effects on the human.
Her Nancy grace has been super into pop full us like six months.
How's she been?
She looks to pot.
She smokes it constantly.
Just making that up.
Yeah,
but maybe she might should probably lighten up.
She probably realizes she's got to get out of that business.
It's bad Karma.
She's in the business.
Talk about the crime spree in Denver.
She that the crime sprees here,
like what are you talking crime spree is here.
It's made its way to Florida directly proportion there.
Um,
this guy that I had this conversation with the conversation was worried about
what happens in 2016 because in 2016 snaps over and becomes Super Republican and
then you know,
things sort of go in and out.
Yeah.
I mean look,
the had the 60s he's worried what will happen if it goes super republican.
Yeah,
yeah.
the 60s and then you had the seventies and eighties,
which was Nancy Reagan.
Just say no.
I mean that's all within two decades.
This is your brain on drugs.
Remember all that shit.
It seems like when it snaps back to it's not smack harder,
harder,
moderate.
The go like hard.
And then people are like,
that's the one I'm like go super hard democrat.
That goes super.
And then eventually one of them is win or outlawed.
The other one,
they'll four in the rush tug and it'll be over or the aliens attack the aliens
land.
And then we go to us.
Remember when Ronald Reagan said that?
What do you mean you never remember that Ronald Reagan gave the speech that all
the Wacky Ufo dude's always point to evidence that the alien invasion is
eminent.
It was Ronald Reagan talking about how quickly we would abandon our differences
if we faced a threat from an alien world.
And when he said it,
people were like,
what the fuck did you just say?
Like it is an interesting way.
No way he would say that other than if it was aliens sort of,
he was putting things into perspective.
I mean it is kind of,
we would realize that we are citizens of the world.
If we were facing a threat from another world,
we would,
it would be us versus them.
The ultimate US versus them.
Oh yeah.
It'd be planet earth pull.
Pull that up Jamie.
Cause it's quite fast and Roddenberry's view of the world later was like earth
comes together because the French region,
but that's it.
Listen to this,
that little freak you out wraps.
We need some outside universal threat.
I occasionally think how quickly our
differences worldwide would vanish if we were facing an alien threat from
outside this world.
Yet I ask you is not an alien force already among us.
What could be more alien to the universal aspirations of our people's war and
the threat of war.
That's a great God damn speech,
by the way.
You know Ronald Reagan was an old fuck and he,
he,
he died confused and selling arms to Iran and allegedly forgetting about it and
he's one of the good Republicans,
right?
Yeah.
I guess back then he wasn't loved.
I remember when I was a kid,
when Ronald Reagan was president,
people fucking hate it.
Oh really?
Oh my God.
They hated him.
Especially towards the end.
They hit all the guys,
all the presence.
So sick.
She'd because somebody off,
do you know Jimmy Tangle is no political comic,
political comic and back then in Boston he was just starting to become
political.
He was at a tape of ladies.
Yes.
We'll say at the comedy store and I suppose I put just like new comics.
Here's that shows the comedy and I hadn't talked about.
Some was on,
it just ate and it
started.
It was just starting.
How many days have you been into comedy?
Yeah,
he must have just less than a year.
Less than year,
and he was on tape and then you've got our city hall because he's watching with
Mitzi in the back.
He goes,
sometimes you just,
I forgot what he,
something like alongside you just don't got it.
Go home,
go home.
He said that about Doug Benson.
Cut it to make it seem like that.
I don't know.
Wow.
That's dark.
It was pretty funny.
But Jimmy tingle had the best job.
That was 2020 it was on 2020 yeah.
What was it about the comedy store?
I was just on the comedy and I'm,
it's unconscious people.
Doug Benson was up there bombing on 2020 I mean he recovered,
recovered nicely.
Very well.
He did very well.
Jimmy single was on there too.
Hey,
if I was eating a plate of shit up there too,
I jumped at the chance to be on 20th,
20th chumpy credits and ate a fat pile of shit fat pile.
Jimmy tingle had this great joke about,
um,
when Ronald Reagan got in trouble for that,
he was,
um,
he was testifying in front of Congress and he said,
uh,
you know,
do you,
um,
did you sell arms to Iran?
And he was like,
I do not recall.
It wasn't,
let's put it that long and tingle.
Yeah.
And tingling goes,
Mister President,
when you sell arms to people who hate us,
jot it down.
Write a note,
put it on your refrigerator.
It's like in that heavy,
heavy Boston accent.
That's funny.
Really funny.
Jimmy Tango.
How many?
Uh,
he's got 1,536 tweets following 11,000 people.
People,
more people should follow him.
He was a funny fucking more followers and followers.
There you go.
Oh,
here's what I can tell you to tell them the story of how you got that
development deal.
What Sussman did.
Sossman is a wizard.
Yeah.
I A had a development deal to do an offer to do a show on MTV.
And how much was that offer,
Joe?
I don't remember.
I don't really remember the money story I heard.
I think I remember it being like $500.
It wasn't more,
it's like a technical amount,
but it wasn't like,
it wasn't much.
It was somewhere around that.
It wasn't much at all.
It was like they give you money for a week to do this pilot.
It was really cheap.
And then if you did that pilot,
you were locked up for like years.
Like it was,
he locked up for like some long term contract.
So,
um,
Sussman decided to take my tape and then he was sent it out to all these
different development companies like NBC and CBS.
Yeah,
he,
well he's just a wizard when it comes to planning a shit.
So he sent this thing out and said,
hey,
this guy's about to sign a development deal for MTV.
Um,
if you want to do something with them,
you've got to act now.
So you create like this domain.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden my phone was ringing off the hook.
I had to leave my apartment.
I couldn't stay in my house because people are calling me.
They were sending me the same sand,
they're going to send a flight out for me.
I'm going gonna fly out of La Tonight and uh,
meet us out in,
or fly out of New York tonight,
Munis and La in the morning.
And,
uh,
you will have a 10:00 AM morning meeting with this guy at this executive and
this fucking network,
this fucking thing.
Like,
it was craziness,
right?
So I talked to Saltzman Saltzman goes,
don't answer the phone.
Just go to the pool hall.
I'll call you that.
I didn't even have to cell phone back then.
No one had cell phones.
This is 1993.
Right?
So I,
um,
I take off,
I go to the pool when within two days it had just gotten completely crazy.
And then,
uh,
I think like a couple days after that I had a development deal with Disney,
Disney one out and the next thing you know I was fucking flying out there and
talking to those guys.
Yeah.
Flying to La and talking to these people.
Gary Valentine stayed in my hotel room with me because Gary was a out of here.
Yeah,
Gary was out here.
Huffin and Kevin James had just one last comic standing.
So Kevin,
which has every lesson was not last comic standing,
excuse me,
Star Star structure starts with Kevin One star search.
So it was like a big deal.
Onstar.
So you definitely want a few rounds,
whatever it was.
Maybe want it.
I Dunno.
Um,
he was fun.
He was really good.
Kevin James,
a very underrated comic,
very underrated.
Stand up the time he was killing it,
man.
He was killing,
he doesn't do it much anymore cause he does a lot of movies.
But anyway,
um,
so within,
I got $150,000.
That's hilarious.
One 50,
150,000,
150 grand.
I went from being broke to 150 $200,000 craziest thing ever.
And then from then he just used their ability to like not be able to decipher
themselves like,
oh,
somebody else likes to look.
Hold on.
Well,
he was also pissed off because the executives at NBC or a MTV rather,
they had this idea and the idea was that they had created stars,
so they're like,
they did it with Denis leary and Dennis,
really?
You're left.
And so they were like,
we're not going to do that again.
Like we create stars.
If you come with us,
you're going to make it.
It'll make you famous.
We don't have to pay you.
So they didn't want to pay much money.
Yeah,
that's still the thing.
It's like,
and I know we mixed our was like sometimes not anymore.
Remember that?
Listen,
that fucking boat has sailed.
That boat has gone.
It's not in the harbor.
You can't even see it on the horizon.
That's a joke.
There's a million fucking cable channels now.
The idea that your one network,
it's valuable is preposterous.
Back then it was valuable because there weren't that many fucking channels.
There was no history channel and discovery channel,
Saifai,
Spike TV,
all that shit didn't exist.
So MTV fucking Netflix now x box and and their own channel.
It's over.
Direct TV has their own shows.
Back then it was like MTV had remote control and MTV created Jenny McCarthy.
Yup.
And they created Chris Hardwick.
A lot of people forget that Jenny McCarthy show.
He was the fucking guy who was on it with the,
and for the longest time Jenny McCarthy was a famous one and Chris harder cause
the one that nobody who knew who the fuck he was and he fancies humongous.
Now Chris Hardwick is bawling because we're past world.
He's took over the podcast world and the nurse Chris,
Chris Hardwick with Jenny Mccarthy and some chick who's got a nice ass.
Very nice common electric power.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's a booty for the agents was on that show.
Yup.
Oh Wow.
This is all,
when I was an open miker this shit was going on there.
A good joke.
When he,
when we were at open mics together.
What do you still drink?
It was this weekend.
I learned something at a wedding.
It's never okay to spill beer on a baby.
Ooh,
it's true.
Yeah,
What was that other show?
MTV remote control.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Or MOCA.
Show salt that may Colin Quinn.
Yeah.
It didn't really though.
Made Adam Sandler.
Colin Quinn.
People didn't know he wasn't it.
It really making the time I live made them.
It got them known to be on tire live.
Got Him a little fame.
Where's Ken Ober?
Remember that guy?
He was a jeweler.
Oh,
control
died.
Oh,
congratulations.
He died in 2009 wow.
Verizon will not turn on my Internet service.
Wow.
New York life is,
she's 52 complaining of headaches.
Chronic chest pain.
Flu like symptoms.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
I Dunno man.
That's fucked.
Look at Colin Quinn there.
Holy Shit on the far right.
The guy laying down.
Probably contestant maybe.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Remote control.
That was another big MTV show and it was supposed to be taking,
placing like Ken Obers basement,
like video that the idea was that his,
his parents had a basement and he always wants to have his own show,
so we put a show together.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Something like this.
They had a show with a,
the chick from the Brady bunch.
It was a talk show called Ober and Olsen.
Really?
Yeah.
Dennis leary was on remote control too.
That's what launched him.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then MTV started doing these things for them.
All these little promo clips.
It's hilarious.
Promo credit rents.
Yeah.
And that's sort of what made them,
and then you know,
showtime special,
whatever it was,
showtime,
HBO or whatever the fuck his specialty.
They have fucking nano girl soon.
Adam Sandler look at the girl's hair behind them.
It's interesting.
That's like from his show that 80 showed the wedding singer.
God Damn,
the 80s were weird.
That is so weird.
Look at the eighties man.
What year was this?
Shit?
1987 don't get sun,
dare you picture,
but don't guess,
don't gas always look.
It was in syndication.
89 to 90 really?
Yeah.
It ran for five seasons from 87 to 1990 they had five seasons in three years.
I don't know how you'd do that,
but um,
yeah.
Mtvs first original nonmusical program.
Wow.
Really new episodes were made for first run syndication.
You convincing them,
hey,
I want to do something in the network that you just don't do.
I don't know.
We want to do any music.
Break it up a little bit.
The people that I talked to that were over there,
they wanted to break it up a bit.
Oh,
you know who?
What it also made Carrie were you remember her carry wherever she is still hot.
She's 47 well,
that picture isn't it?
Yeah.
Look at the picture.
That's her.
No,
no.
That's her from back then.
But if you see there's a picture of her now and Wikipedia.
Gosh,
she's cute.
She's still hot.
She's got that a sexy mill thing going on.
Kapow Kapow Citizenship Cambridge.
Is that her now?
It looks,
that's hard today.
I'm still in shape.
So unsafe,
powerful.
Kerry war were or where were here where her I was on.
I'm politically incorrect with her.
No really way back in the day,
like in 1990 something I think.
I think it was like,
I want to say,
I want to say it was the fear factor days,
but it might have been before that.
It might've been the news radio days.
I'm not even sure.
I know I was on at least once.
Yeah,
there's Carrie.
Carrie were were were,
were were though is.
I don't remember at all.
She's hot as fuck you back in the news radio days.
Sexy as fuck.
Let a hair almost almost full.
Starting to go kind of shirts too.
I love those big over the elbow.
Yeah.
I think was the news radio days and then after that was the a I did it again on
fear factor.
Oh,
that shirt.
No,
no,
no.
That show politically incorrect.
Whoa.
That was before he got in.
Remember he got in trouble for saying that we're cowards for fucking launching.
Never lost respect for him.
Why'd you lose respect for him?
Not for that because he didn't stand up for it.
No.
Cause when I saw him this first show on an HBO afterwards,
he's like cursed and it goes,
this is why we wanted to come here.
This is why I wanted to get off network and come here like,
bitch,
you got thrown off pretending like you're responsible for that.
Begged for your job back.
He's a rebel.
The fuck you talking about?
Do you not know?
He's a rebel.
He's a,
that's what I like about it in the most,
he's a reference a dude.
He's a rebel.
Okay.
Wrecking Verizon.
Maybe wait three times all day long for God damn technicians who never showed
up.
What does it have to do with Kerry war?
Where was the thing?
I just keep thinking about it and you're all angry brown.
I supposed to come on Saturday.
Verizon fries Internet.
Oh you fucking,
you're really angry there right now.
It's the worst.
And you call and be like,
sorry,
I get so angry at like the customer service.
I know they're not to blame,
but it's like fucking what time they going to be.
Stop saying you're sorry.
Stop it.
It's an insult.
Three days I've given up just waiting there for people that don't show up.
No.
So really guarantee with be done.
It'd be on by 5:00 PM today.
You're very upset.
Did you know how you go to someone's page and you know them on Twitter,
but then they don't follow you and you get sad?
Yeah,
that's what I just went to carry.
Where were his page?
And she's not,
but I'm not following her.
So he just remembered her for the first time.
It's 20 years saying easy.
I'm trying to be nice looking at a recent picks.
No,
I just followed her on Twitter.
Whatever recent picks.
Put them up.
It's pretty man.
Yeah.
Let me see.
She's hanging in there.
You know what?
I saw a TV show the other day and wonder woman was on it.
You can't put them.
Oh really?
How was she as a motherfucker?
Aw.
Times a motherfucker.
Time is such a motherfucker.
Linda was ended up hard time.
Time.
See what's become of me.
Yeah,
look,
it was become a her.
She that chick.
Oh,
the bags go.
Not so good.
Really?
Oh No,
no,
no.
I'm confused.
She's actually still pretty.
Uh,
for whatever reason I associated her with Jace grace.
Slick from uh,
from Jefferson star ship.
The tall black lady.
No,
that's Grace Jones.
That was the one who Dolph Lundgren.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
She didn't date flavor.
Flave you shit then she is a vet.
No,
no flavor.
Flave was the girl used to be married to Sylvester Stallone.
Who was that?
Bridgette Nielsen.
Yeah.
Oh,
she was the one who dated flavor flip.
Yeah.
Confusing everybody.
Man.
I barely know you.
Actors.
I barely fucking know you.
That's your legacy.
Ah.
Um,
the grace slick was the lead singer of Jeff Jefferson star ship.
I need to go a lot of those Mexico.
Yeah.
Grace Slick was hot at one point in time within times a mother fucker.
Dude.
Time doesn't wait.
Time gives no fucks.
Time keeps swinging.
Even if your down time kicks you.
It was cool being,
let's wrap it up.
But this is,
uh,
come back to the beginning.
It was cool being a forbidden city and the Great Wall of China and tucked in
these walls.
They like this has been here for a long time.
Yeah.
What did that feel like?
It just was this cool connection to the past.
I mean it's not real,
but it just imagine this like emperors have been by here and touch this.
How about the Mongols?
They built it to fucking fight off the step people.
How did they did the matching separate?
Imagine walking through the forest,
trudging and marching through the forest up and down mountains is mountainy
forests and then you're getting not even close to look their land and then all
of a sudden you're like,
what
the giant wall that you could see from space.
Get the horses up there.
I'll go around.
You'd March three miles like all guys do even know which way is the end of this.
There's no end.
How long is that wall look at you?
You sexy bitch with no shirt holding the fucking Chinese flag.
I love taking my shirt off back.
They just think all the Chinese Bikini,
they just took this up and the men walking around like that.
Why did you like taking your shirt off?
I love taking my shirt off.
I know his son in me.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Keep pushing.
Keep it closed on me here.
So I walked out to the top password.
People like stop walking and then there's one guy is like,
if you go another as many kilometers,
that's like tower 23 that's as far as you can go.
And I was like,
fine,
cause I'm doing it.
So you walked all the way to the end.
It was so hot and so humid and so many steps.
Irregular shape steps.
It was so hard.
How long has the Great Wall?
Like what is the total district?
We got up somewhere.
We got up to somewhere near where this Toboggan to get down.
Okay,
let's find out.
But yeah,
it's the only manmade object.
Viewable from space.
Okay.
The Great Wall of China.
Jesus Christ,
5,500 miles.
This is it.
That's insane.
Is that right?
5,000 what?
5,500 miles.
Is that right?
Longer than the United States of America.
It goes up and gets windy too.
It goes up and over things.
Is that really right?
Okay.
Maybe.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Undertaking was that.
That's like some pyramid level shit,
right?
How many really?
That's about it.
Yeah.
It's 8,850 kilometers,
which is 5,000 just a straight up wall.
There's,
there's battlements you could stick your Arrow through and fire down without
getting shot.
It's all built.
Well,
that's so crazy.
I didn't know it was that long.
It goes on forever.
I figured it was like a hundred miles.
That's what I thought.
My head.
I was like,
Eh,
a hundred miles probably.
That seems like long enough.
That's the not so great wall.
That's a wall.
Look how far it goes.
That's crazy.
Oh my God.
We are looking at a map right now.
It's a greater great wall.
That's what it says.
Is that what it says?
Lengthen outbreak.
Extended sections.
What?
Why would they keep building a wall?
They do this a lot where they go,
uh,
we're going to Redo all this stuff.
We're going to upkeep
it,
and they just replaced the wood.
They were placed,
the,
the stuff they just like as if someone was still living here,
we're just going to keep it,
keep it going.
Wow.
Yeah.
Weird.
It shows like they built and then date renovated will be like 45 years ago.
Right.
But why would they extend it?
I don't know.
Make it more of a,
Is it a tourist trap?
Is that what it is?
They extending it for,
for more tourist traps.
I went outside Beijing.
Okay.
Wow.
What else can we do this,
why else would they do that?
That doesn't make any sense.
Did you know the South Korea was smushed up against China?
Like that?
Where's that?
Oh,
right over there.
That's an insane,
like,
it's so much bigger than Korea.
It's fucking huge.
I can't believe the wall was that big.
Maybe they just hate pink Floyd
down.
Shit.
I'm gonna keep going up even in the years after this is relevant as a defense
force,
but you,
did you,
um,
ever see the renovations are doing to the Sphinx?
No.
What are they doing?
It's Kinda sad putting those back on.
No,
they are doing,
they fix up the feet and shit and they're,
they're patching up the body,
but they're not really,
what they're doing is they're building their own version of it.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because they're covering over the Sphinx.
Like they're making the feet all smooth.
Like Jamie pull up the actual stone has something to it here,
not the design.
This is what's been here,
this object.
It's just a really soft stone.
And it's like,
it's all worn out and shit style letting it flow down.
Yeah.
No Shit.
But they don't do that.
How long it lasts on it.
So what do these pictures,
cause it's Kinda,
it's Kinda gross because what they're doing is they're making the feet all
smooth and shit.
And like the word pause,
our was totally irregular.
Let's go to the video tape surveys.
What do you uh,
I found a page.
There was an Egyptian and just look up images,
do a Google search and images as Jamie instead of failing.
Why don't you not fail?
How about,
you know,
fail fucker.
That'll get you see the right hand corner like that.
That shit is all just renovation.
That's not what the feet originally looked like.
What is it?
What do they go over it?
See all those little bricks?
Yeah,
the,
it was originally carved out of one unique set of stone.
Oh,
they're just putting new brick song.
Yes.
There's smoothing it all out.
It was what's called a Yardang.
What a Yardang is,
is something that comes up out of the desert and then they shape it.
It's like,
um,
it comes up out of the ground like a rock structure.
Would it bricks?
Exactly.
Oh,
it's so stupid.
Like bat back.
See if you can get some other photos of it.
You could see the food it was like before.
Yeah.
See if there's that,
but there's a full image of the Sphinx where you could see it from a distance
and you can,
you get a real sense of like that one,
the right hand corner.
You get a real sense of what a travesty that is.
What they're doing is really kind of fucked up because what they're doing is
it's just too bad.
They're making their own shit.
Like those feet are not the original Sphinx.
They're all smooth and bricks all over him.
The rest of the Sphinx used to be everything below the head,
all jacked up.
Fucked up.
Ward off some like demon or something?
No,
no,
no.
Well the,
the thing,
the thinking is rather that originally it was a lion and that one of those
pharaohs,
one of the Farrells was like fuck that line head shit in my head because they'll
face is fairly African.
So they believe that it took place after the Newbie.
Ian's conquered Egypt because there were two different types of people that were
ruling in Egypt.
The Sephardic people,
the original Egyptian people,
which are always depicted as,
you know,
like Arab looking folks.
Like Cleopatra was always depicted that way or you know,
Arabic a little bit.
Yeah,
I see dash well they actually look kind of strange,
you know,
like have you ever seen like what two ton common really looked like a recreation
of two ton common?
No.
Ooh,
it's weird,
weird,
weird head man.
He's got his,
uh,
he had like an elongated skull.
His whole family had elongated skulls and they had,
um,
uh,
sculptures that were drawn of him.
That was what,
that was a recreation of what he looked like.
But that doesn't look as weird as when you see a side profile.
See if find out.
He died super young too.
I think he died.
Lexington like,
yeah,
like 17 or 18 or something.
But like,
look at what it's
like they were freaks man.
Yeah.
And I don't remember who his father was.
See if you can find out who it's for.
I think his father was a,
I want to say taught Moses,
but I might be wrong,
but whoever his father was like a chicken from kids in the hall.
I'm knocking how cannot and yeah,
that's,
that was what it was.
And [inaudible] had this very strangely shaped head and they have these
sculptures that were created of [inaudible] and I mean,
he looks like a God damn alien.
Look at,
look at it,
look at what he looked like because his fucking head and they don't know if
whether or not it was,
that was a result of head binding was.
That could be,
but it would also could be some weird genetic uh,
you know,
issue that some of those guys had.
And that's one of the reasons why they head bound in the first place to try to
recreate that.
Did it might've been,
you know,
like some people have strange slips,
some people at big jaws,
some people have,
you know,
they might've just naturally had weird shaped heads and they became bad
motherfuckers and then they all interbred there was a lot of that going on.
No royal blood,
fucking other royal blood or Florida state had a like that pump store maybe that
way.
Yeah,
it was all weird in the back.
It looked like the alien from above the head.
Hold on.
What's that?
That's his real head.
Wow.
That's two to uncommon.
Is that to done Kamara Ahca Naughton,
jpegs says it's knocking on was two ton common knocking on that.
Not the same guy.
That's a crazy fucking heads.
I'll look at this guy and it's like an extra three inches wide or a long run
there.
Stop right there.
So strange.
So who was the dude that wasn't the store was a black one.
Black Bob,
sir.
His head.
No,
it wasn't.
it was this black player they played with the Florida state that wants the pros.
Afterwards he shaved his head.
Fuck,
I forgot where he played and he had a crazy shape.
10 crazy shaped.
What would you do if you had a crazy shaped head and you had your head shaved my
head.
But what have you had do?
What if you're black and you're going bald?
Black guys can't rock like this side.
Like,
uh,
you know,
it doesn't,
I can't have to side here and bald on top of the Christmas wreath.
It doesn't look good.
Yeah.
What do you do?
I don't know.
Do you think they do something about that?
They put like implants in there shaped the back of your head better?
No.
Well think about all the shit that they do do.
Thinking about all the shit they do for like the straighten their hair.
I read an article recently about South Korea and the,
uh,
the thing about Saudi Arabia,
oh my God,
it's crazy.
It's so common that I do it in China.
Two girls are getting their eyebrow eyeballs done.
It's like a rite of passage.
You got to cut them so you can have an overlap and you're on your eyebrows.
Eyelashes,
whatever that's called.
I live,
it's like ours fold over.
Oh yeah.
There's don't fold over.
Oh Shit.
So they want to get him to look like they fold over.
So like at the surgery,
what did they look like with their eyes closed?
I think normal with her eyes closed and then when it's up it's like there's no
like lip,
you don't have to like folds over the top.
Yeah.
In South Korea.
I think Bobby's mom got that surgery.
Bobby Lee,
she's Korean.
Boom boom.
That proves it.
Why does it Bobby get it done?
How weird would that be?
False it and Bobby Lee and these crazy like,
like what?
I'm weird.
I was like man,
I just don't belong on here.
That's it.
Pull up Sam Casell Samka sales head.
Yeah.
See the one that won a Heisman and still play basketball.
That was Charlie ward put up sandcastles.
Ha.
Yeah.
Side Angle of cause cell.
Look at this shit.
Yeah.
It gets rid of their things before and after.
Wow.
Let me see.
Pull up a picture of that dude's face or a head rather,
and it's hard to tell in that picture.
Did you fill up Sam [inaudible] head?
Yeah.
Do a Google search son.
Learn how to Internet.
Isn't this ridiculous?
Yeah.
Did an amazing job with [inaudible] face.
Everything about her face was,
it was different.
Well,
yeah.
I mean she became super hot.
Oh,
so I guess it's worth it.
It's like one of the rare instances where some of these chores mirrors like it's
super effective.
Some of these girls,
you got to get a little more back,
but that's still looks,
that's pretty,
pretty ochin Naughton.
Yeah.
That's pretty nuts,
Sam,
because that's a weird fucking head man.
That was a weird head son.
Look at this one.
I want to see a crazy one.
We have this South Korean transformation.
I mean this is,
but I thought he was telling me that.
Wow.
She went to a what to wow.
Yeah.
Look at that.
What?
That's crazy.
Pull up some.
She looks like an old lady and she looks like an amazing 24 year olds.
Yup.
She looked
disgusting and then hot and it is clearly,
if you see the jaw line,
it's clear.
The same woman.
They must done a lot of shit on her.
Look up South Korea eye surgery and you could see that that image,
there's a bunch of 'em man.
It's super common.
What's it called?
There's a phrase for it.
Snuck a pool.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
Wow.
Whoa.
That's nuts.
She covered her chin.
She said dime.
No,
it looks use the word dime.
Like I'm a black.
I worked so much time son.
She looks,
she has down syndrome and the first one and then she looks gorgeous.
Yeah,
she looks like down syndrome.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's a whole a website dedicated.
It's called 30 startling before and after South Korean plastic surgery pictures.
That's like,
it's like a advertisement for plastic surgery.
I guess that's why it's so common.
Look at that.
Look at that one.
Wow.
Cause it works.
Change your life.
Yeah.
Really.
I mean all of a sudden.
Did you hear about that one guy who sued his,
his wife because his kids were ugly and it turned out that she had gotten
plastic surgery.
Wow,
that's rude.
I think he wanted to,
oh yeah.
Hold on man.
Whose wife?
Cause kids were ugly.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we're ugly.
Oh,
why the dude look good to Whoa.
Yeah,
he looks a lot better.
Holy Shit.
That's incredible,
man.
Successfully Sue's wife over ugly children successfully.
What country?
America?
Fuck no son.
Okay,
please speak.
Chinese man divorced his wife and sued her for giving birth to what he called
extremely ugly baby girl.
At first he thought his wife had cheated on him because there was no way.
Hey,
good looking guy like him could have or even produce such an unattractive that a
real article.
Yeah,
it's the same lady.
It's that that was the image actually it was her.
That was her.
What?
Arabia that Emison MSF and then they showed the image of the check and then the
image of the kids and the image of the woman.
She was stupid hot at the end.
Look at,
look at how hot she was.
She's there with him so he thought he had like the Super Hottie.
Look at those ugly kids.
Look at that was fucking up.
The kids,
their mouths go down or all their fucking kids.
How rude can you take them in for a little chop and snip and you can't do it to
babies though.
Oh,
he'll grow out of it.
Oh fuck them up.
And the nightmare when asshole.
You'd have to be to get plastic surgery to a baby cause fat little son.
He's not weird,
man.
That's so weird that people are doing that.
I'll face smile.
So doing it so much that it's changing the way they ve envision a woman should
look so much so that it's like super change.
Common.
Wow.
Super Common.
Weird,
right?
Yeah.
It's just a strange and so oddly affective to South Korea.
Now has the highest number of surgeries performed per capita overtaking Brazil
as the plastic surgery capital of the world?
Those all as implants?
No,
they don't want any of them.
I don't need directions.
Probably South Korean woman have become so immersed in western celebrity culture
that double eyelid surgery,
that's what it's called.
Which creates the Caucasian crease.
Many Asians don't naturally have,
has become as common as going to the dentist.
Wow.
Okay.
I got to go to sleep common as I owing to the dentist.
Think about that.
I want you to jerk off.
Think about plastic surgery in South Korea.
Meanwhile,
the doctor that does it.
Yeah.
Agents fuck looking.
Can't do it to themselves.
Nope.
There's not one.
He's not interested in trust.
Anyone else with lesser talent than hips?
Like this is stupid.
These people are crazy.
There's no reason for it.
I got to take the training with blend in.
Debunked.
It's debunked.
You rang untrue to me.
Well,
I don't like that.
I don't like it.
It's probably false.
I feel like I just got ripped off.
What would you,
what did you get that from?
What debunked it?
The way he was quoting to casually of the way with a good looking man like me
and probably right.
Dammit.
Mother fuckers a arch fear.
Where can a,
the the,
the ladies and gentlemen see you doing your stand up?
Well,
I'll be in Calgary and a September,
middle of the temporary Yucky ox and I guess I'll be in Chicago.
Calgary Yuk.
Yuks I heard was one day on the 26th Calgary's fun dude.
Oh yeah,
it's great.
You do Calgary with me.
Do we do times a few times there.
Those are fucking animals.
My rise.
It's chucks.
Even like two years he was like,
you sold out.
But like you had this trouble selling out that place and next year no press sold
out two shows.
Oh that's right,
that's right.
They'll get people behind us.
Remember Jacques Singer?
Jazz singer.
Yeah.
That was crazy.
As people behind us remember like they were up above.
Oh yeah.
Turn around and wave to him like I was that,
that one.
Yeah.
That was also the place where the oversold it and they didn't know what to do.
So they put seats on the stage on the stage.
That's what I mean.
Remember?
Yeah.
And like the giants,
they don't need all that room,
but they were going to not do it.
They were going to give those people their money back and send them home.
And so I said,
well,
you know I don't like,
that's okay.
Like you want to see them on the stage,
you can see them on the stage and so there was like a pow in a meeting and they
go,
okay,
we're going to see,
we're going to put the seats in our chairs out there and there was like 200
fucking people on the stage.
Canadian unions,
they finally got that shit set up in no time.
We're on the stage.
There's a lot of God damn people on the stage.
It was maybe 200 there was mad on the stage.
That was fun,
man.
Calgary's good.
Those towns like Edmonton,
Calgary,
like there's a lot of oil money.
Those folks have a lot of oil money.
How to party and they party.
They party hard.
They go hard.
Yeah,
we did a Lloydminster.
Lloydminster is like a mining town.
The early hours from Edmonton.
That's cool.
Yeah.
It's like they look,
they look at Edmonton like all look at him open this.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
We were on,
we did a show in a hockey rink.
Really?
Yeah.
Callen Tony Hinchcliffe in me in a hockey rink in Lloydminster at a great
fucking time.
Sound system was kind of dog shit.
It was what threw me off a little bit.
It was tough because it was echoing a lot and I was on the side when Collin was
onstage and clear,
I couldn't hear him.
Damn.
I was on the side and I could barely understand what he's saying and I knew his
act and the people at the front got it.
Good.
Fuck yeah.
Had manners.
No,
the crowds here already could have a good time.
It's like,
I know and you're not making them have as good a time as good a time as they
could.
All they had to do was set it up a little bit better,
put speakers in some different areas,
but now we know they don't do shows up there.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
They're trying to figure it out.
Yeah.
You met Harvey,
the promoter guy.
Yeah.
He's a good dude.
So we,
we did it up there with him.
All right.
This fucking shows over are you should fear.
This is the second of two podcasts we did today,
man.
It's crazy.
Brothers was,
hey,
I sold that couch.
So we've got to go to dinner sometimes too.
Original couch from the original Joe Rogan experience podcast.
I gave it to Ari years ago.
He kept it in as a park ranger was the nicest thing in my apartment for five
years.
Easy.
Ah,
very nice couch.
And so,
uh,
then some dude bought it.
Yeah.
How much you got for that fucking thing?
40 bucks.
Holy Shit.
Iba.
Two,
let's go to like a Morton's.
Yeah,
some really nice glass of wine.
Like gentlemen.
All right,
let's do it.
Alright,
follow Ari on Twitter.
Ari Shaffir,
a r I.
S h,
a f,
f.
I.
R.
M.
And you can also get his standup comedy.
What is you,
you have to stand up comedy cds that are available to comedy specials that are
available.
One that chill went down so it passes the guess if,
I guess comedy central's going to put it up.
Well,
I went down chill the website that did mine,
and Maria's improves as,
she can't buy it anywhere to buy it right now.
So revenge for the Holocaust is still out,
but there are illegal downloads.
Oh good.
You go to views player and put in passive aggressive or should fear,
you could probably find a seed for it,
but revenge for the Holocaust is to cds out.
Yes.
That's out.
And the other one is not out.
Not Out.
God Damn.
Yeah.
Passive aggressive.
It's just out there in the ether somewhere.
We're getting it up.
So you get put,
but right now they've got the green light to hit the torrents.
Yeah.
Oh absolutely.
The full green light.
Powerful Greenland.
All right.
Oh,
and I have a story to tell or show on Monday.
union hall.
But there's only like 40 seats.
So New York.
Yeah,
New York.
Oh,
beautiful.
Pat's doing it.
Oh Shit.
Ms Paths going to be on the podcast.
Oh,
it's,
you're going to love her.
You're going to love it.
Keep hearing that,
man.
She's going to be on the podcast on,
I think he's a nice warm Tongan.
Ninth Tuesday,
29th.
Yeah.
July 29th.
Awesome.
All right.
You dirty fucks a,
we'd love the shit out of you.
We appreciate you very much and uh,
I appreciate it even more after being gone for a week.
I enjoyed this.
This is an awesome day.
Alright.
Uh,
we'd be back tomorrow with the dude from unbox therapy and,
uh,
lots of podcasts coming up.
Fight companion on Saturday,
Brennan shop and me.
I watched the fights together.
All right.
Much love,
big kiss.
See you soon.
Oh,
and my sponsors are awesome.
Dot ting.com.